I want us to have a self-sufficient
human population somewhere other than
earth because 25 years of being a
computer programmer has taught me the
value of backing things up Andy weir was
working as a computer programmer in
Silicon Valley when he began writing the
Martian and serial form and posting it
for free on his personal website five
years later he had a book deal with
crown publishing and a film option with
20th Century Fox the movie directed by
ridley scott and starring matt damon
comes out this october and follows the
story of astronaut Mark Watney as he
struggles to survive on Mars after he's
mistakenly left for dead in the wake of
a botched mission we sat down with weird
to talk about his amazing journey from
programmer to best-selling author the
challenges of writing a scientifically
accurate space novel and his thoughts on
the future of real-life space travel
Andy thank you very much for talking
with us thanks for having me so the
story behind the book itself is actually
almost as interesting as the book which
is that you self published the book
online and then somehow 20th Century Fox
found it and adapted it into a movie
starring matt damon could you just tell
us take us through that journey oh you
know it's the same as anybody else you
know once you self publish something it
gets made into a movie by Ridley Scott I
always wanted to be a writer but I also
like the idea of eating regular meals
and stuff and so when the time came to
choose a career i went into computer
programming and that's fun i like it but
you know it's always wanted to be a
writer i set up my own web page for my
own creative efforts i did a bunch of
webcomics short stories stuff like that
and one thing i would post or serials I
post a new chapter every mon every 22
months or so and sometimes I just go
months at a time without working on it
and it was just a serial that I was
working on and I put a lot of work into
making it scientifically accurate
because my regular readers based on the
size of my mailing list were science
dorks like hard are hardcore science
dark side about 3,000 regular readers
and I you know my web comics and stuff
for geeky stuff
and so I knew that I had to be
technically accurate otherwise it would
like kind of break realism for them and
I never had any notion that the story
would be popular in the mainstream I
thought I was worried i thought this was
a story by a nerd for nerds doing it in
the serialized form and having this kind
of instant feedback from this Legion of
nerds reading or material do you feel
like that affected your process at all
and affected your writing did it make
you a better writer it did because of a
couple of things first off getting the
feedback helped motivate me and that's
one of the biggest challenges for me
anyway as a writer and I think for
others to is actually sitting your ass
down and writing and knowing that there
were people eagerly waiting for each new
chapter helped really motivate me to get
it done the other thing that was cool
was that I had 3000 fact checkers so
just like there's nothing a nerd loves
more than telling you you're wrong on
math and i can i can confirm this
because i myself am a nerd and so any
math errors or whatever in the in the
chapters as i posted them i would get
emails and say like well you got this
wrong you got that wrong so that really
helped with the scientific accuracy so I
just kept posting chapters and
eventually I finished and when I was
done I thought like okay I'm done on to
other projects other cereals and then I
started to get email from my readers
they're like hey I I love the I love the
Martian but I hate your site because my
site socks and they're like and it's no
fun to read a book on a website can you
just make an e-reader version so I did
that and I posted it to the site and
then I got other emails from people
saying oh hey I'm glad there's an
e-reader version but I'm not very
technically savvy and I don't know how
to download a thing from the internet
and put it on my e-reader can you just
post it to Amazon Kindle so I figured
out how to do that I said all right
folks you can read it for free on my
website or you can pay amazon a buck to
put it on your kindle for you i was
required to set a minimum price of
ninety nine cents so i set it at
ninety-nine cents pulling down a cool
thirty cents per copy royalty i'll have
you know and i just turned it loose and
it sold like tens of thousands of copies
it was it was selling really well and it
worked its way up to the top of the
bestseller list in amazon like that top
sellers in science and
stuff like that after three years
earlier in life of not being able to get
an agent at all one comes knocking on my
door I'm like sure and within a couple
of weeks David had me on the phone with
random house and working on a book deal
and so while they were negotiating that
Fox came for the film rights by the way
at this time I'm a computer programmer
so I'm here bike I'm in my cubicle
working on bugs and then sneaking off to
a conference room to take a call about
my movie deal then back to my cubicle
fix more bugs wow that is incredible and
what is the lesson that you take away
from going through that process I put a
lot of work into trying to figure out
what the hell did i do right because I'd
like to do that again right i I don't I
I did not expect it to have mainstream
appeal and the only thing I can think of
is that I think as just as a society
people are more educated on science than
ever before and so they can appreciate
more detailed science fiction so I think
that your book in a way represents the
kind of mass popularization of science
you're wearing a shirt right now it says
I'm going to science the something out
of this yeah could you explain why
you're wearing the shirt and and what
you think about the public's attitude
towards science in 2015 well this is a
line from the movie it's actually a drew
came up with this line it's not in the
book so people often credit me with this
quote but it's not it's it's it's a
quote from Drew Goddard and well to
quote from Mark Watney as written by
Drew Goddard and it pretty much sums up
the the entire book and movie of the
Martian science and popular culture is
getting more and more popular it used to
be scientists or whatever we're just
nerds that were kind of marginalized by
society and I that's no longer the case
now there's like geek chic type stuff
and i don't mean the brand name i mean
that i mean we have like celebrity
scientists know we have young neil
degrasse tyson and Bill Nye Richard
Dawkins how do you feel about science as
a sort of cultural force I love it I
love that people are starting to like
respect and venerate
demak and scientific achievement because
that makes your society smarter over
time it means that it means that like
kids growing up now will now grow up in
a society where it's like oh look that
guy who's like smart and scientific
minded is cool maybe maybe I want to do
that and i honestly think a large part
of that I mean this is like kind of
cynical of me but a large part of that
is I think comes from the software
industry and where I spent 25 years of
my life and people only started to like
nerds when nerds started to make triple
the median income all of a sudden like
along with the tech boom came a bunch of
like wealthy nerds then all of a sudden
societies like Oh nerds are neat I like
nerds nerds are rolling in now nerds are
rollin in it and ignoring the anomalous
like super successfully of Bill Gates
guys but just talking about the average
computer programmer makes you know well
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
and it's like all the sudden nerds are
cool in a past Q&A you described your
politics as socially liberal and
fiscally conservative do you consider
yourself a libertarian not like a
capital L libertarian at all smile
libertarian I guess I generally try to
steer clear of discussing politics at
all I don't want people to think about
my political views when they're reading
my book why is that why is it that you
don't like that you you kind of
consciously avoid inserting any of that
into your writing if I'm reading a book
about it dude stranded on Mars I don't
want I don't want some you know agenda
involved in the book and it ruins a
story for me because you sit there and
go like it's isn't just like not only is
the author preaching at me but the
universe of this book is going to align
to validate his point of view and it
ruins things it's like I okay I already
know who the good guys and the bad guys
are going to be I already know that like
this guy can't be the murderer because
the author is making this political
point or whatever Robert Zubrin who's
president of the Mars Society he wrote
an article that was actually published
in reason asking the blunt and somewhat
uncomfortable question how much is an
astronaut's life worth and zubrin's
question to be clear is not asking about
a rescue situation per se but about
precautionary measures because the
is kind of an unlimited amount of money
that you could spend because you can
never reach perfect safety at what point
do we stop spending money and actually
send someone up out of the atmosphere
into this horrible scary vacuum called
outer space do you think it's possible
for governments to adequately balance
those two concerns absolutely possible
and I think they do it and a really good
example of how governments do it isn't
so much with astronauts but with air
travel so governments have to decide
what are the requirements for aircraft
like what you know okay so what what
safety requirements do we want to put on
a plane because there are there are
things you could do to make planes even
safer but eventually you're starting to
be like okay well now a ticket you know
from New York to LA is going to cost
twenty thousand dollars or something
like that so they worked out there's a
formula and I forget exactly what it is
but it's something like they say if you
can increase safety by if you can like
decrease mortality odds by a certain
percentage it's worth spending this much
money to do so if somebody comes up with
a method that'll be like okay well we
can increase safety by this much but it
costs and it costs more than that then
like the u.s. like the FAA is like we're
not going to we're not going to
recommend it the same will eventually be
true of space travel right now
everything's a case-by-case basis
everything's special and it's actually
really dangerous we have sent something
on the order of between five and six
hundred people into space ever total and
on the order of 20 of them have died
that's pretty bad odds there's a scene
in the book where a reporter asked like
at what point are we spending too much
here to save Watney and the answer as
well there it's kind of a special case
because they're getting an extended Mars
mission out of it so from a strictly you
know dollars per amount of time spent on
Mars Watney was like this fantastic deal
the trend in space travel over the past
few years has been towards privatization
and in the book it's a NASA mission
going to Mars do you think it's possible
that a private entity someone like an
Elon Musk is going to actually get to
Mars before the government
I know I don't think that's possible or
likely but I do believe that commercial
spaceflight will be absolutely critical
in the first manned mission to Mars I
think the first manned mission to Mars
will be a large international effort
kind of like ISS and so I think you can
expect NASA Ross cosmos jaksa ESA ISRO
the Indian Space Agency maybe even the
Chinese will all work together and and
collaborate and and do a manned mission
to Mars and that's going to require some
big-ass ship put in orbit now either you
use cyclers or you use ion engines or
you use good old-fashioned propellant
either way you're gonna have to put an
awful lot of mass in orbit that's where
commercial spaceflight is going to
happen it'll be messy politics right
because it's so you'll have a whole
bunch of countries involved so it'll be
like all right SpaceX gets 17 of the
launch as era steed gets nine of the
Russians get for that you know the
Japanese get to you know whatever it
would be something like that you can
think of it as a company that makes
widgets in New York and wants to sell
them in LA doesn't make their own fleet
of trucks usually they hire a trucking
company to do the transport and that's
what it comes down to companies like
SpaceX our freight companies and they'll
drive the price down and down and down
and that's the key by the way people
have always said like oh going to Mars
is going to cost you know several
hundred billion dollars I don't think it
will because I think by the time we're
actually considering it the price till
Elio will have gone down a lot because
of commercial space travel and basically
the price to go to Mars will come down
because that's the main thing getting
things from the surface of earth to
earth orbit the price to get to elio
will come down until it reach you know
multi government cooperation will go up
in the amount they're willing to spend
on it will go up until there's some some
point at which they say like okay it's
now 20 40 and we're pretty sure we can
get humans on Mars for 50 billion
dollars you know what is the most
compelling case to send a mission to
Mars the real question is why would
anybody send a human to Mars because we
have really good robotics technology we
have really good computer AI right now
a rover is not as efficient as an
astronaut would be but give us another
20 years of tech or I tell you what take
some of that hundred billion dollars
that it would cost to send humans to
Mars and put that into developing the
tech and you will very quickly end up
with Rovers that are at least as
effective as astronauts and have enough
AI to make minor decisions on their own
so let me ask the question so why human
to Mars and the answer is because the
Rovers are what you want to send to Mars
if what you're after is information
about Mars I have a different goal I
want us to have a self-sufficient human
population somewhere other than Earth
because 25 years of being a computer
programmer has taught me the value of
backing things up and as as long as our
entire species is on one planet we risk
extinction it's not very likely but it
could happen it could be a plague it
could be a war it could be a meteor
strike or something like that but if
we're on two planets it is practically
impossible for us to die Andy we are
thank you very much for talking to us
thanks for having me for reason TV I'm
Zack why smaller a half long paddles
that use the air around them to create
pressurized cushions of air on which the
pod can ride look like a monkey table